si os preguntara cuál es la mayor
compañía de comercio electrónico del
mundo estoy convencido de que la mayoría
de vosotros responderéis sin dudar que
amazon sin embargo amigos puede que esto
no sea del todo así atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
olivas universidad widener gente letrina
pública merz muy vendido internet wi-fi
el cultivo del país- móviles en el fin
[Música]
con un valor de mercado de más de 400
mil millones de dólares y más de 600
millones de clientes en todo el mundo
alibaba una increíble historia de éxito
es también la empresa china más valiosa
que podemos encontrar en todo el planeta
y es que amigos esta empresa se ha
convertido en algo así como el mejor
icono de todo lo que supone el nuevo
capitalismo chino
[Música]
fijaos regresemos un momento a la
pregunta que nos hacíamos al comienzo de
este vídeo es amazon la mayor empresa de
comercio electrónico del mundo pues
amigos depende
[Música]
[Aplausos]
si por ejemplo nos fijamos en el valor
de mercado es decir en cuánto valoran
los inversores la compañía entonces
indudablemente sí lo es
amazon es la compañía más grande pero si
en cambio nos fijamos en el volumen de
ventas que cada año se realiza a través
de la empresa es decir donde se compra y
se vende más entonces alí babá gana por
goleada
si puede que alibaba no sea una empresa
tan popular y tan conocida como lo es
amazon al fin y al cabo opera
fundamentalmente en el mercado asiático
pero aunque eso nos puede pillar un
poquito lejos lo cierto es que cada año
a través de las diferentes plataformas
de alí babá se venden productos por
valor de más de 750 mil millones de
dólares
[Música]
ahora bien a los que seguís
habitualmente visual política estoy
convencido de que todo esto no es algo
que os vaya a sorprender
asia está viviendo toda una revolución
un despegue un proceso de crecimiento
económico que no tiene precedentes cada
año cada año que pasa cerca de 160
millones de personas dejan atrás la
pobreza y logran pasar a formar parte de
la clase media 160 millones de personas
tan solo en este continente en apenas
unos pocos años países como filipinas o
tailandia tendrán clases medias tan
grandes como el reino unido francia o
italia y luego esta china cuya clase
media está literalmente explotando
despegando casi en vertical
y amigos qué ocurre cuando una persona
deja atrás la pobreza y pasa a formar
parte de la clase media pues entre otras
cosas
eso significa que ahora tiene mucho más
dinero para gastar esto es lo que
explica que el mercado de consumo
minorista en china se haya multiplicado
por cuatro en los últimos cinco años y
que las previsiones señalen que tan solo
el crecimiento del consumo chino en los
próximos tres o cuatro años va a ser
mayor que todo lo que consumen hoy los
británicos o los alemanes
[Música]
y sabéis quién tiene más de un 70% de
cuota de mercado en el sector del
comercio electrónico de china y está muy
bien posicionada en el resto de países
asiáticos de mayor crecimiento exacto
alibaba
los futbolines claustros seguro que
ahora ya empezamos a ver a esta empresa
con otros ojos verdad
[Música]
pero antes de echar un vistazo a las
características de alí babá a sus luces
y sus sombras veamos dónde y cómo surgió
todo veamos su historia
[Música]
el milagro de jackman
y nunca fue el mejor estudiante pero
gracias a los turistas extranjeros que
visitaban su ciudad natal y
especialmente a la relación que entabló
con una familia australiana jackman un
niño ha nacido en una familia humilde
apenas dos años antes de la revolución
cultural de mao logró aprender inglés y
conocer todas las posibilidades que
brindaba el mundo moderno y amigos como
pasa tantas veces en la vida no fueron
los estudios formales sino esas pequeñas
experiencias a las que muchas veces ni
siquiera prestamos atención las que
alimentaron el éxito de quien hoy es el
hombre más rico de toda china soy 100%
hecho en china aprendí inglés yo solo y
no sé nada de tecnología una de las
razones por las que alibaba sobrevivió
fue porque no sé nada de computadoras
soy como un ciego montando en un tigre
ciego también jackman jackman uno de los
héroes de la nueva china moderna no pudo
acceder a ninguna buena universidad sin
embargo gracias a que sabía inglés logró
graduarse en magisterio trabajar como
profesor de idiomas y a los pocos años
a una empresa de traducción y
precisamente en un viaje a los estados
unidos para realizar un servicio de
traducción unos amigos de seattle le
enseñaron lo que entonces era una
incipiente tecnología llamada internet
en ese momento
ajax se le encendió la bombilla tenía
miedo de tocar la computadora porque
parecía muy costosa pero ellos dijeron
vamos jacques adelante no es una bomba
entonces este que la palabra cerveza
cerveza y pude ver cerveza alemán y
japonesas pero no china luego teclee la
palabra china y la respuesta fue no hubo
resultados entonces pensé que
interesante si pudiéramos agrupar a las
empresas en china y crear para ella es
una página tal vez lograríamos algo
grande jackman dicho y hecho nada más
regresar a china ya que montó una
empresa sign up page para listar
clasificar y poder así encontrar
compañías chinas algo así como unas
páginas amarillas
esta empresa no tuvo el éxito esperado
pero ya que aprendió lo suficiente para
estar listo para su siguiente aventura
tras mucho trabajo en su pequeño
apartamento
tanto de él como de un equipo que había
logrado formar prácticamente sin
recursos en 1999 nació alibaba hoy una
de las corporaciones más grandes del
planeta
[Música]
el gran mercado
más que preguntarnos qué es lo que hace
alibaba deberíamos preguntarnos qué es
lo que no hace
porque amigos veréis alibaba más que un
portal de comercio electrónico es algo
así como una especie de intermediario
tecnológico es decir a diferencia de
amazon la vocación de alí babá no es
vender directamente nada sino
fundamentalmente funcionar como un gran
mercado donde miles y miles de marcas
productores y empresas de distribución
venden sus productos a millones de
clientes es decir alibaba es la empresa
propietaria la empresa que gestiona ese
gran mercado y además suministra todo lo
que las marcas los productores y los
distribuidores necesitan para poder
llevar a buen término su negocio desde
la plataforma de pago hasta los
metadatos
de hecho si puede que esta sea la mayor
diferencia respecto a amazon por ejemplo
pensar en la enorme cantidad de datos
que manejan estas empresas tendencias de
consumo presupuestos tipos de clientes
timing de las compras etcétera etcétera
pues bien mientras que amazon utiliza
todos esos datos para desarrollar líneas
de productos propias
alibaba a los comparte con las empresas
que operan a través de sus mercados para
que sean estas quienes lancen nuevos
productos o conozcan mejor las
preferencias de los consumidores y así
logren vender más y que el mercado
crezca qué es lo mismo que decir que
alibaba crezca de esta forma con el paso
de los años
alibaba ha desarrollado muchos mercados
diferentes así que si os parece para
entender mejor qué es exactamente
alibaba echemos un vistazo a cuáles son
estos mercados y en qué se diferencian
por ejemplo alibaba.com es un enorme
mercado mayorista tal vez el mercado
mayorista online más grande del planeta
es decir este mercado no está orientado
a los consumidores a través de
espacio los productores los fabricantes
venden sus productos en grandes
cantidades a otras empresas para que
luego los distribuyan en sus países que
por ejemplo tienes una tienda y quieres
encargar 5000 camisetas rojas con un
determinado logo este es tu espacio a
menos que utilicemos alí babá es
extremadamente difícil costoso y
frustrante encontrar a un proveedor
alibaba acortó el intermediario hacen
que sea extremadamente fácil de
encontrar comunicarse y negociar con los
proveedores directamente a través de su
sitio web ya hay un empresario e
inversor luego en china además del
mercado mayorista local que en este caso
se conoce como unos 688 puntocom
alibaba tiene los dos mayores mercados
de comercio electrónico minorista del
país
taobao y timol
veréis taobao es más o menos una
combinación entre amazon y ebay y aquí
prácticamente cualquiera puede vender
sus productos es un mercado con miles y
miles decenas de miles de proveedores y
casi 600 millones de consumidores
activos
timol en cambio es como un gran centro
comercial online orientado a grandes
marcas aquí las marcas pagan una tarifa
por tener su propia tienda vamos como si
fuera un centro comercial de los de toda
la vida
y luego una de las joyas de la corona
menos conocidas
alibaba es propietaria de más del 80% de
la sada la empresa de comercio
electrónico más importante del sur de
asia una empresa que opera en países
como indonesia vietnam malasia singapur
tailandia y ojo porque no estamos
hablando de algo precisamente pequeño
tan solo en los próximos dos o tres años
estos países van a ver como su clase
media se multiplica por dos hasta
superar los 400 millones de personas 400
millones de personas que alibaba quiere
convertir en sus clientes
y ya por último tenemos la que
probablemente sea la plataforma más
conocida por la mayoría de nosotros
aliexpress una plataforma orientada al
consumidor internacional bien pues estos
son amigos los principales mercados que
actualmente forman parte de alí babá
pero las actividades de la compañía no
terminan ni mucho menos aquí
alibaba también es una de las cinco
empresas de cloud computing es decir
servicios para empresas en la nube más
importantes del mundo y desde luego es
líder indiscutible en china y ojo porque
esta es una división cuyo ritmo de
crecimiento en los últimos años ha
superado el cien por cien anual
compañías como kpmg nestlé phillips o
sap ya utilizan los servicios de alí
babá
y luego también es propietaria de
youtube una plataforma de streaming
similar a youtube de lm la empresa de
entrega de comida a domicilio más grande
de china y además entre otras muchas
empresas tiene una importante
participación en huevo que sería algo
así como una especie de facebook chino
pero un momento habéis escuchado hablar
de alipay para los que no sepáis lo que
es el ipe y es muy similar a paypal
tiene más de 870 millones de usuarios
activos y es el líder del mercado chino
de pagos móviles
[Música]
y es que veréis en china las tarjetas de
crédito no son algo común los chinos han
saltado directamente a los pagos móviles
de tal forma que cuando van al
supermercado en vez de utilizar una visa
o una mastercard para pagar sus compras
utilizan alipay o los servicios de pagos
de widget que son los dos grandes
servicios de pagos que hoy lideran el
mercado chino pues bien alibaba es
propietaria del 33% de and financial que
es la empresa dueña de alipay y también
de pay tiempo que es la aplicación de
pagos móviles libertad en la india- otro
mercado con fuerte crecimiento para que
os hagáis una idea de lo que esto
significa la valoración estimada de and
financial supera los 150 mil millones de
dólares
pero por si toda esta apuesta online
fuera poco alibaba también está
invirtiendo miles de millones en el
negocio de supermercados y tiendas
físicas donde ya tiene su propia marca
hama y además es el mayor accionista de
sant art del grup el mayor operador de
supermercados e hipermercados de toda
china
es decir como veis el imperio alibaba
extiende sus tentáculos sobre un montón
de sectores dicho de otro modo
alibaba tiene servicios equivalentes a
los de amazon ebay
just-eat visa youtube facebook e incluso
carrefour todo en una misma empresa no
está mal verdad pues bien esto es
precisamente lo que explica que esta
compañía valga en bolsa más de 400.000
millones de dólares pero creo que no
podemos terminar toda esta historia sin
hablar del futuro
[Música]
con riesgos y oportunidades
amigos los planes de alí babá son muy
ambiciosos
para el año 2020 las ventas realizadas a
través de las diferentes plataformas de
alí babá superan el billón el billón de
dólares
[Música]
y en tan solo 18 años la compañía aspira
a superar los dos mil millones de
clientes
[Música]
si ese es el objetivo lo conseguirá pues
evidentemente no lo podemos saber pero
lo cierto es que tiene muchas papeletas
veréis a pesar del enorme crecimiento
que ha tenido esta empresa desde su
fundación en 1999 aún tiene mucho
potencial no solo porque el comercio
electrónico está creciendo una
barbaridad en todo el mundo sino porque
además todo apunta a que particularmente
en esta región el crecimiento va a ser
bestial por muchos años echemos un
vistazo por ejemplo a china el principal
mercado de alí babá aquí la penetración
de internet es de apenas del 55% es
decir aún queda mucho recorrido al alza
hablamos de cientos de millones de
personas que tarde o temprano se
conectarán a internet y empezarán a
realizar sus primeras compras online y
no sólo eso como además el poder
adquisitivo de los chinos crece con
mucha fuerza año tras año lo mismo
ocurre con los importes medios de compra
fijaos desde el año 2015 el gasto por
cliente de alí babá en china
un 50% así que si combinamos más gasto y
más clientes como podéis ver el
potencial es gigantesco y luego está la
región de los países de la asociación de
naciones del sudeste asiático la india
etcétera etcétera y es que amigos de
visual política esta zona del mundo no
sólo va a experimentar un enorme
crecimiento económico sino que además se
prevé que durante las próximas tres
décadas su población crezca en más de
700 millones de personas todo ello
además del mercado internacional claro
ahora viene un momento porque no todo es
tan alegre como muchas de estas empresas
de internet que focalizan toda su
atención en crecer y crecer la compañía
apenas gana dinero
[Música]
en este caso hablamos de una empresa de
400 mil millones que apenas ha
conseguido tener en los últimos 12 meses
un beneficio neto de 8 mil 400 millones
de dólares si si puede parecer muchísimo
dinero pero el valor de mercado es 50
veces el beneficio neto y eso es
bastante y claro me podéis decir vale
vale pero qué más da ya ganará dinero en
el futuro pues puede que sí o puede que
no porque un mercado que crece tanto
también suele conllevar un incentivo muy
fuerte para la llegada de nuevos rivales
algo que en cierto modo ya está
ocurriendo
competidores como hey dot com sobre todo
pingo duo están invirtiendo mucho dinero
para rivalizar con alibaba y aunque a
pesar del éxito que están teniendo tal
vez nunca logre superar la tal vez sí lo
cierto es que añade más presión que
reducirá los márgenes con los que estas
empresas pueden operar en el futuro y
luego por supuesto está el gobierno
chino que como sabéis no es precisamente
un gobierno democrático que respete el
estado de derecho y que apueste por la
seguridad jurídica en china os lo hemos
contado ya el gobierno hace y deshace
como le da la gana y eso puede
determinar incluso quién sobrevive en un
mercado y quién no vamos que como le
llega mal un envío a un líder del
partido comunista podría llegar a ser
una pesadilla
[Música]
en fin amigos en cualquier caso es
evidente que alibaba es la mejor muestra
de los cambios que está experimentando
nuestro mundo de como asia está
adquiriendo cada vez más y más peso y de
cómo ya empieza a tener sus propias
grandes multinacionales
acostumbrémonos si te ha resultado
interesante este vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual política un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]